every Wednesday our morning round series
looks at medical issues that affect you
and solutions that help you get
healthier about 13 out of every 100
couples cannot get pregnant it's a
stressful and emotional time and it's
often considered to be a female issue
but the CDC says both men and women
contribute to infertility infertility in
about 35 percent of couples and the man
is the only factor in about 8 percent of
cases our dr. taryn Rula is here Tara I
think it says something about this
subject and also probably about me that
I feel the need to point out I have a
new baby at home you wanted to know
you're working I assure you there's no
problem thank you very much but there's
a stigma attached to this men don't like
to talk about it there is and that's a
big issue you know a lot of men equate
fertility with virility and sexual
potency and it's unfortunate because the
two are really not the same thing and so
they tend to feel if I can't conceive
there's something wrong with me they
feel emasculated they feel guilt and
shame and anger and anxiety and
unfortunately they don't talk about it
they keep it very private and in the
literature it's been documented that not
only do they feel they can't talk about
it I don't get a lot of support from
their family but also in the medical
world they don't get a lot of support a
lot of the support is focused on the
women and even online women have
community groups and support groups on
Facebook and the men really don't so you
know we are in a culture we don't really
ask men how do you feel about not being
able to have a baby or do you want
children we just really kind of avoid
the subject with men and it is
unfortunate so what are the common some
of the common causes down so there are a
couple different causes and we break
them out into four categories there's
idiopathic meaning we really have no
idea and that's about 10 to 20%
everything I know about 60 to 80% is
something wrong with the test the
testicle something wrong meaning it
could be either genetic acquired
structurally environmental exposure
toxins about 5% have to do with a
hormonal problem the brain has the
pituitary gland the hypothalamus that
secrete hormones that essentially
stimulate sperm production and there
could be something wrong with that
pathway and then about 5% are a
transportation problem there's some
issue with the sperm getting out of the
testicle no I've heard you know
and listen I'm not a doctor of course
but riding a bicycle or wearing tight
bike shorts right so there are some risk
factors to that and this is why it's
really important for him to see I'm
trying to help other men increasing the
temperature of the testicles you can
have some issues with sperm production
so that's why part of the questioning of
men includes asking about hot tub or
sauna use but there are a lot of other
risk factors like being overweight obese
smoking alcohol use environmental toxins
and exposures and even testosterone gel
or implants that men might be using
so maybe boxers not briefs maybe boxers
all right all right thank you Karen one
of the risk factors isn't fortunately
talking about it is not a risk factor
yeah we talked about it